[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
étincelante rutilantes les mustangs ont
investi le parc du château de la
verrière en nombre ce samedi la ville a
partagé un peu d' american dream la
voiture est sortie en avril 64
1964 c'était à l'époque une voiture
destinée aux secrétaires aux assistantes
voiture bas de gamme destiné à
concurrencer les autres marques du
moment et une voiture à la carte le
plein d'options ce qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui on trouve peu de voitures
avec le même modèle les mêmes options
[Musique]
avec cette belle journée profitez la
mustang comme il se doit c'est-à-dire le
coude à la portière et avec du plaisir
c'est une voiture plaisir au fait
[Musique]
comme car nathalie près de 70
passionnément gros du mustang france
sont venus avec des véhicules deux
premières cinquième et sixième
génération l'événement a débuté avec une
balade en vallée de chevreuse
l'engouement qu'elle procure le plaisir
on le remarque tout le temps le
particulièrement en france il ya il dès
qu'on s'arrête tout le monde qui va nous
voir c'est il ya un engouement du public
est fantastique et comme on partage
cette passion qu'on n'est pas un club
élitiste qui restons un peu chez nous
mais qui faisons profiter comme
aujourd'hui
la mustang et la voiture de sport la
plus vendue au monde pour l'année 2019
et les curieux ont répondu présent lors
de cet événement la mairie évalue le
nombre de visiteurs à plus de mille
curieux taille club du bouchon on peut
les voir tranquillement et à regarder
les petites merveilles les voitures sont
jolies
on a une journée exceptionnelle surtout
nous avons envie de partir aux
etats-unis et pourquoi pas en musth en
1360 euros ont été récoltés au bénéfice
des restos du coeur lors des baptêmes
organisée dans l'après-midi une remise
de chèque va bientôt être organisée par
la commune une deuxième édition est
d'ores et déjà envisagée
[Musique]